bueno y es cierto lo que dicen algunos
analistas putin espera poder terminar
para el 9 de mayo el 9 de mayo se
celebra este gran desfile de la victoria
de la segunda guerra mundial entonces
este redobla sus esfuerzos cambia
reposición a sus fuerzas militares para
ocupar otros espacios inicialmente no
estaban considerados y así poder
presentar una victoria esa sería común
si hubiera una fecha en la cual ésta
está trabajando y operando
después de ti no es esa la fecha lo que
queda ahora es la capacidad de
resistencia por parte de los ucranianos
de resistencia en términos de no sólo de
los armamentos provistos por occidente
de que también redoblado sus esfuerzos
para enviar a todo tipo de armamento y
el sobre todo al momento especial para
el nuevo teatro de operaciones sino
también la capacidad de los de rusia de
resistir digamos de poder justificar las
pérdidas entonces si en algún momento
estas partes
encuentran que no pueden no pueden
resistir o no pueden superarlos sus
víctimas superan el umbral
soportable entonces el camino a la paz
el señor corbacho y en ese sentido que
tendrían que ceder rusia y ucrania para
que hubiera eventualmente una salida
diplomática todavía hay esperanzas de
que haya una salida diplomática a este
conflicto la única salida que hay es
diplomática no pueden llegar a un
acuerdo sí por supuesto
como yo como les decía me parece que lo
que estaba pasando ahora que putin está
cambiando su
tu plan de ataque no está reposicionando
sus fuerzas a ocupar toda la zona
sureste y avanzar hasta moldavia o sea
esto sería adueñarse de la costa o de la
región costera de de ucrania que era
parte de los objetivos iniciales
en el medio capel tuvo antes otros este
sería como el tercer reposicionamiento
que hace
y el inicial era bueno aún a aplastar
fácilmente y rápidamente a los
ucranianos esto no lo logró ocupando
gran parte de su territorio
la segunda parte fue bueno concentrarse
en algunas en algunas ciudades y más en
la región de las provincias detrás del
donbass y esta última es avanzar más
sobre la costa del mar negro entonces si
alcanzan esos objetivos y si ucrania
está dispuesta a ceder porque el tema es
que en estos además de las pérdidas
humanas de ambas partes las pérdidas de
material la pérdida de riqueza la
pérdida de patrimonio cultural y estoy
vivienda todo esto las partes tienen que
llegar a la conclusión de que no vale la
pena seguir y lo harán y llegando a un
tipo de acuerdo lo harán por supuesto en
la cual ambos se presentarán como
ganadores o cómo magnánimos este
pacifistas no por eso putin se ha
detenido un poco sus ataques masivos
contra mariupol desde arrasar totalmente
la ciudad la ciudad está arrasada
no no está terminando destruirla como
podría hubiera querido hacerlo